antoine bonjour alors le président de la
république est en ce moment à marseille
les habitants attendent beaucoup de sa
part comment est-ce qu'on est arrivé à
cette situation notamment au niveau
sécuritaire à marseille
bonjour olivier alors et le 24 août en
avec gabriella talent qui nous annoncer
que emmanuel macron venait à marseille
qu'on a et se donner les moyens pour
pilonner les trafiquants je cite l
évoquer notamment le renfort de 100
policiers de 200 policiers d'ici la fin
de l'année ensuite en à gérald darmanin
quartier la mort qui annonçait le
renfort de 300 policiers d'ici 2023 il a
rappelé qu'il y avait deux compagnies de
crs qui était constamment attaché à la
ville dorénavant puis là on a les
amendes emmanuel macron qui nous annonce
200 policiers d'ici l'année prochaine et
quelques 150 millions d'euros pour la
police marseillaise donc où on a aussi
misé de l'intérieur qu'elle réagit à
cause d'une vidéo qui a été tournée pour
un magazine télé dans laquelle on voyait
des trafiquants qui faisait des vrais
checkpoint en fait dans la cité des
flamants donc
à marseille et il ya des interpellations
qu'on était donc annoncer cela mais en
fait il a surtout fallu une quinzaine de
règlements de comptes au cours de
l'année 2001 terme pour arriver à ce
résultat
politico médiatique avec un très fort
sentiment d'abandon de la part de l'état
dans les quartiers nord de la ville et
c'est aussi le sentiment que partagent
les policiers par ailleurs et c'est sur
cet aspect que nous avons concentré
notre travail pour un article qui est
paru la semaine dernière sur notre site
internet alors antoine est ce que vous
pouvez nous rappeler quel a été
l'élément déclencheur du coup de
projecteur sur marseille
alors la goutte d'eau bien entendu ça a
été la mort de ce jeune de 14 ans qui a
été tué par balle
et qui on a vu également un jeune de 27
ans qui a été tué sur la méthode dite du
barbecue mais la carotte et brûlé vif
dans son véhicule mais
aussi choquant que ce soit en fait un
officier marcellier de la police
nationale que nous avons contactés nous
a rappelé que d'une part il y avait déjà
eu des morts de 14 ans notamment un
jeune de en 2009 qui avait été rafale et
sur sa chaise en plastique alors qu'ils
dînaient en bas de son immeuble dans le
13ème arrondissement de marseille et
puis cette méthode du barbecue elle
n'est pas nouvelle non plus que sa
classique marseille depuis depuis de
longues années il ya même un trafiquant
donc en 2006 qui a été tuée
qui était surnommé le rôtisseur pour
cette même raison
alors qu'antoine qu'est ce qui a changé
à marseille et que pour emmanuel macron
face au phénomène du trafic
[Musique]
alors notre source policière à marseille
nous a décrit une lente mutation des
clans qui selon lui ce sont organisées
sur des critères ethniques c'est à dire
que il nous expliquait qu autrefois dans
les années 80 les trafiquants corse de
marseille se tuer entre que finalement
ça ne dérangeait pas tant que ça la vie
de la cité
comme nous l'a expliqué mais depuis une
quinzaine d'années il ya ce sont les
petites mains du trafic en fait
d'origine plutôt maghrébine qui font
l'objet des règlements de comptes tandis
que il ya toujours quelques parties
tiennent des corses qui tiennent le
marché mais depuis l'étranger
selon ce policier les dealers maghrébins
sont progressivement en train de
reprendre le marché du stupéfiant il
semble peu probable en fait que le
gouvernement accroît qu'il reste
seulement une poignée de mois d'exercice
malgré une longue visite du président
sur place puisse endiguer un phénomène
qui dure depuis plusieurs décennies ont
donc c'est que tu peux être aussi le
fait que l'elysée elle expliquait dès le
début on sait que le manuel maquereau a
dit ce ne sont pas dans les quelques
mois qui restent dans le monde de ce
mandat que vous verrez les premiers
effets de deux sont en train de faire
aujourd'hui qu'ils préfèrent communiquer
sur l'urbanisme à l'éducation plutôt que
de trop trop entrer non plus dans le
sujet de la sécurité peut-être merci
beaucoup antoine antoine boîte l on peut
retrouver vos articles sur notre site
rtl france point tv